let's say in the way that the people
watching this will totally understand
you can't completely just act as if God
exists yes
exactly
you know it's gonna yeah it's gonna act
so but that's why like I tell people
that ultimately the Psalms are the good
example this is that ultimately worship
is the key to this like word it's like
it's because worship places you in a
mode where you're interacting where
you're acknowledging where you're
placing yourself in relationship to this
this to to God and then and then that is
the training right that's the training
ground which helps you exit you know not
just make it into a mental trick but
make it into something that you embody
that you participate in no I I think
that's absolutely important I think
that's that is the kind of real thing
ultimately is worship right and uh
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
so hello everyone I am very pleased to
be here with Michael legaspi who is a
professor of the Old Testament at Saint
Vladimir Seminary as you know many of
you probably know the same Vladimir
Seminary is one of the main OCA
seminaries uh in America it has a very
long and profound history all the
theological developments of the you know
Orthodox Church in the west this
transfer to local languages Saint
Vladimir has been very much involved and
so I'm really happy to be able to
collaborate with them and with Michael
so Michael thanks for thanks for talking
to me
um no it's a it's a pleasure to be here
Jonathan thank you for having me on this
um wonderful show which has been just a
wonderful thing for so many of us out
here in the you know the uh the internet
sphere I suppose so thank you so much
for for having me it's great so so
Michael had this wonderful idea to go
into the Psalms uh and look at this idea
that the Psalms are in some ways a way
for us to experience our own personhood
our own subjectivity uh and a kind of
frame for for us to experience that and
I thought it was a wonderful idea so
maybe Michael you can start us off and
kind of give give us your main thesis
about this this the function that the
Psalms can play in in this
right so I guess just kind of in
reflecting in my on my own relationship
with scripture
um I've sort of noticed that there are
just kind of ways in which the
scriptures make sense to me in ways in
which I feel like I'm hindered in my
understanding of them and my progress
toward them
um and sort of as I thought about it I I
thought a lot of the issues that I was
having just as a as a an individual were
tied up with kind of my notion of self
and
how I interact with God and with the
world and this sort of brought me to
this idea of of subjectivity right so
this idea of
um what it means for me to experience uh
life as as me and what it means for you
to experience life as you and sort of
all the things that go into that right
sort of Consciousness emotion perception
all of these things influence the way we
um experience the world the way we
interact with others and the way we
interact with God and um as I was
thinking about it like we we tend to
like work with like a few options when
it comes to subjectivity right so we
think of our ourselves our Consciousness
our interaction with the world is as
sort of cognitive right like what do I
think and what do I know and that sort
of makes me who I am uh and that kind of
orients me toward the world so I have to
come up with the right world view I have
to come up with the right philosophy so
that I can uh kind of consider my you
know have the right relation to what I
experience
um another way of thinking about
subjectivity is in our effective way
like thinking about emotions and
attitudes right so obviously those
things affect the way we experience the
world so fundamentally what makes me me
is it my personality I don't know about
you but like I like those personality
tests you know and I've taken a lot of
them and you know I find that really
interesting and maybe that is something
that like determines our our
subjectivity is like something affective
about us
um or we could go materialist right and
we could say that subjectivity is
essentially a reflex of kind of our
existence as physical beings right like
emergent property is what they like to
say emergent proper emergent property
properties right yeah exactly
um but I I think that any of those ways
of like thinking about subjectivity sort
of limit us when it comes to interacting
with God reading the scripture
um and I think it's the Psalms in
particular that helps us recover I guess
what we might call a kind of scriptural
uh subjectivity so
by that I mean that we don't like
exclude the physical or the cognitive or
the effect of like all those things are
definitely part of The Human Experience
uh but I think what Psalms show us is
that subjectivity uh human subjectivity
is fundamentally relational that what
makes us who we are as beings and what
kind of is at the core of our
interaction with the world is our
capacity for relationality specifically
uh for relating
um to God which I think in the Psalms is
presented as like the fundamental uh
relationship
um so and that I mean I just want to
mention one thing because if you realize
then that when Christ says that you know
the the let's say all the Commandments
are gathered in to love God and love
your neighbor what's being enunciated
there in some ways is not just an
ethical command it's not just a the way
that you have to act but the way we have
to be that it's a it's Annunciation of
what it means to be a being in itself
that a being is has to be in
relationship with in relation to others
that's how it works
right so like how do we move from the
kind of domain of the self to something
outside the self I guess is a question
and do we do it on the basis of
again our emotions our cognitive
Maneuvers or whatever I think the Psalms
kind of anchor Us in in something deeper
and kind of a deeper way to make that
movement that movement that is you know
fundamentally a movement of Love
um
and so I was kind of helped in my
Reflections by this distinction that uh
uh philosopher Charles Taylor makes
right between two models of the self
right so he talks about something called
the porous self which he Associates with
you know pre-modern cultures right so
where people didn't sort of draw this
hard line between themselves and the
world outside but saw the boundary as
porous and so things that happen in the
world uh essentially
um
can be experienced in this in this sort
of direct way there isn't like a a wall
so to speak
um and so this he says goes along with
um experiencing the world in an
enchanted way right so that we we see
we're kind of porous to to the spirits
we're porous to Cosmic forces were pores
to God
um
and that
in this mode you know along with that is
actually a kind of vulnerability right
so you have people who are sort of feel
vulnerable of spiritual forces
um and
he so one of the things that Taylor's
interested in is like what it means for
us to be modern people right and he says
that one of the Hallmarks of modernity
is a kind of shift from the city of the
poorest self where we are kind of feel
ourselves as being connected to and
vulnerable to that which is outside of
us to what he calls the buffered self so
when he speaks of the buff itself he's
sort of talking about a model of the
self in which
um we have like complete control over
the meanings we assign to the world so
we can kind of Stand Back observe things
and decide what they mean and we have
this sort of buffer then that that
insulates us from what happens to us um
and so
not only do we have sort of control over
um
over what we the meanings we assign to
things in the world but he says that
people you know see in this see this as
liberative because it gives them Freedom
like I can assign whatever meanings I
want I can kind of remake myself as I
like and um I think of Richard rorty in
connection with this because you know
he's the one who sort of celebrated our
kind of nichean uh potential to recreate
ourselves
um and you know he says he has this
quote he says there's nothing deep down
inside us except what we have put there
ourselves so it's the kind of buffer
itself and behind the buffer is this
container
um that's completely at our disposal
yeah so I think this kind of modern view
of selfhood and you know I have to say
to a great degree is kind of the view
that I walk around with you know as a
function of you know living when and
where I do and it makes it hard to kind
of relate to that which is on the other
side of the buffer if you know what I
mean if you're if you're kind of
experiencing yourself in this in this
particular way
um but it's interesting that now because
that that way of thinking especially
online especially the fact that we're
physically separated from each other and
we interact through screens we interact
it's as if there's an acceleration of
this like the a notion of the buffer
itself
is manifesting itself in the world and
accelerating even in the means by which
we interact like you and I right now and
dragging through this screen and so
the consequences of it are more visible
right if you think of Avatar culture
like this idea of people self-creating
themselves online through their personas
that are extremely that have become very
strange and you know like they can even
be aliens or furries or whatever like
people will self-create themselves in
ways that have become so idiosyncratic
that it'd be it's almost now impossible
not to notice the the side effects of
this buffer itself like it's fragmenting
and splintering in ways that in some
ways I think
is opening a call of the heart for of
people wanting something more wanting a
more connected reality no I I think
that's an excellent I I do think that
digital stuff and screens sort of are in
a way a kind of buffer right like that's
just the the version of the buffer that
we're kind of working with today and
um and also the thing about the digital
is that it really has this idea of
plasticity and kind of infinite
potential and I can you can rearrange
and reconfigure endlessly and so this
idea that the kind of stuff that we work
with behind the buffer is infinitely
plastic is I think
part of the you could just reuse you
know use and reuse cultural tropes and
memes and you know this bit of song and
this image and you can just sort of put
it all together and create whatever you
want
um
but I I think with the Psalms point to
when it comes to subjectivity is this
idea that it's not infinitely plastic
there is actually something there
um that uh that is god-given
um that can only really be
um at at rest and fulfilled when when
when we come back into communion with
god
um so I think Rory is is wrong there's
there's more than down in there than
what we put there namely
um there is what um what God put there
um
and and I think it's the Psalms that in
in this really unique way kind of tutor
us you know they kind of like lead us
in this sort of manner of living that
reconnects us I think with uh
a notion of the self that's
um not fragmented as you know to use
your word it's but but actually kind of
reintegrated
um so thinking about the Psalms I got a
lot of help from Saint athanasius who
wrote this letter which I encourage
everyone to read it's called the letter
to marcelinus and it's uh it's a a text
uh all about the Psalms and he says some
amazing things about the Psalms that if
you don't mind yeah to share he says
um in other books of scripture we read
or hear the words of holy men as
belonging only to those who spoke them
not at all as though they were our own
and in the same way the doings they are
narrated are to us material for Wonder
and examples to be followed but not in
any sense things we have done ourselves
with the Psalms though except for
prophecies about the Savior it is as
though it were one's own words that one
read and anyone who hears them is moved
at heart as though they voiced his
deepest thoughts
so I think we can think of the Psalms as
sort of given to us
to make the depth of the self
um
accessible to us right that it under
normal situations it's not fully
transparent to us and we fail to
understand the movements of the soul I
guess is another way of putting it and
that the Psalms kind of help us to see
um those movements of the Soul uh in
ourselves so I yeah and it's not it's
not what's interesting too about the
Psalms is that it's not only a kind of
whitewashing like you could imagine it
that way it's like no it's just it's
trying it's immoralizing it's trying to
make you into the right person it's
trying to force you to to think certain
ways no like the cries of Despair and of
anger and of wanting revenge like all of
these are part of the experience of
reading the Psalms it's not at all a a
cleansed uh a cleansed version of Human
Experience it's a very rich and deep and
and sometimes very dark version of it I
I mean to be honest some of them are
difficult to read you know the closely
the prayers Revenge it's and it's hard
to know what to do they're famously
difficult for people to work with you
know maybe we should just be thinking
about the demons as our enemies for
example and
um but I don't know I think some of the
Psalms are about people
but I think that it's if you see it more
as something that encompasses the
fullness of Human Experience right and
tries to so if you see just the song for
vengeance as being isolated on its own
then of course it doesn't it doesn't
hold but if you understand it as this as
a part of a musical Symphony where
there's this moment of of dark you know
and and of anger and of asking God to be
your your hand just to get done what you
want but then there are other moments
where it expands into
into a loftier vision of what what is
was possible you know no I I like that
very much I think and I think that's a
good counsel So reading Psalms together
right it's sort of like you can
obviously take an individual one and do
whatever you want with it but like
taking them together is is I think the
right move just you know interpret which
is actually for all scripture that's
what you need to do because if you just
read the Book of Judges alone you like
you'll go crazy but if you read if you
read you know the the early books and
you read the prophetic books and just
call for all you know the the spirit of
God to be on All Flesh and you get this
big story you then all of a sudden even
the harsher Parts they tend to to look
like like little like little movements
in a grand Symphony you know right right
no that's um yeah and Psalms is a kind
of microcosm of scripture right like
that's another thing you find in the
father there's a lot is this reference
to the Psalms as being like a mini a
mini like Bible unto itself and you know
it was divided into five books to mirror
the five books of the pentateuch because
so it's um it really
it really Bears kind of reading in that
in that holistic way
um so
so yeah so the um
so so if that's true of the Psalms then
like what is our response right and I
think that this is where we have um this
sort of wisdom in the church which is to
to read the Psalms kind of in bulk uh
because when they're brought down into
the heart right and there's a kind of
statement in the Phila Khalia when
they're brought down into the heart uh
they take root in the soil of the heart
and produce the flowers of the spiritual
life right the visions of incorporeal
realities the Luminosity of corporate of
corporeal realities that the judgments
of God which are hard to understand so
um so I think
and and I'm saying it's not as like an
expert basically in doing this or in
spirituality of the songs this is for me
kind of like getting my own
self-oriented toward um the way in which
the Psalms can uh can teach a function
yeah so you have this this so one of the
things you want us to look at which I
think is a great idea is that there are
certain songs which are read at Madden's
right and and are gathered together from
The Book of Psalms and to have a that
they there's a through line and there's
a certain aesthetic to them in which
they deal with this idea of darkness and
you know falling into the pit and
calling up to the heaven so maybe you
can guide us a little bit about the
practice basically because these would
be these would be sung you know if in a
monastery they would be sung at matins
right at every every mat in service
right and so if you if what I mean I've
done matins I don't do it very often but
when I do then I then I engage in this
in in this as well
yeah so I I think it's important to sort
of like see and benefit and understand
uh the guidance of the church when it
comes to the Psalms and I think there's
like amazing things that are done with
the Psalms that sort of clue us into how
they can be shaping our subjectivity and
for me one of the most powerful examples
is this group of Psalms called the six
Psalms um so for those of you interested
in in looking at this um this is their
Psalms 3 38 63 88 103 and 143 or in the
Greek numbering 3 37 82 87 102 and 142.
so they come from across the Salter and
they're they're chosen out and put
together and this group is called the uh
the six Psalms so I think the the matins
context is important because
um
mountains is the morning prayer service
right so if you're thinking about
um waking up you've just come through
the night the new day is beginning and
matins is like right on that boundary
between the night and the day so
symbolically we might say between death
and our waking to a life after death
so
um
and and in um in Russian tradition
um Vespers and matins are kind of done
together as part of the vigil uh before
like say uh you know on Saturday night
say before Sunday in which case the six
Psalms are part of the mountains in our
parade like exclusively at night
um and and so in Russian tradition
um the parish I was a part of they put
out all the candles in the church in the
six Psalms so it was like utterly dark
the reader had just one candle and would
read the Psalms and um read them in a
low voice and in a very solemn way
nobody is moving I actually came across
an ancient typicon which specified how
the six Psalms were to be read and uh
the instructions were really were really
interesting right so one one instruction
is this is in a monastery context no one
may sneeze or spit or leave his place or
move or enter from the narthex if
someone is bent over because of old age
or ravaged by sickness and cannot avoid
doing we have just described let him
stay outside the church until the end of
the hexus almost so there's this
atmosphere uh it's dark it's static and
you're just standing at attention and
you're listening to the songs
and you know having experienced this a
number of times my sense is that the
Psalms the six Psalms kind of bring us
through an experience of death you know
I think like the philosophers talk about
Memento Mori and they talk about
thinking about death as a kind of like
way to lead the philosophical life but
what these Psalms do is I think actually
bring us
through we actually experience death
liturgically
so the very first of the six Psalms is
Psalm 3 which contains the line
I laid me down and I slept I awoke for
the Lord will help me so what kind of
waking is it
um so again there are a lot of
traditions that associate the six Psalms
with with judgment with this idea that
they're kind of preparing us to stand
before God in judgment after death and
so the first psalm
has this image of falling asleep and
waking up
and we wake
into God's presence which is a kind of
judgment God's presence is always a
judgment right
um and so from there the Psalms take a
really dark turn
um and there's just a ton of imagery
there that to me sounds like
us as sort of having passed to the other
side of death are now looking back on
this process of dying you know these
images that seem to match
like they seem to voice the body being
lowered into the grave yeah yeah
um my heart is troubled my strength has
failed me and the light of mine eyes
even this is not with me my friends and
neighbors Drew nigh over against me and
stood in my nearest of kin stood afar
off I picture people at a funeral
standing far off from the body
filled with evils is my soul my life
unto Hades I've drawn Nigh I'm counted
with them that go down into the pit and
become it as a man without help free
among the dead like the bodies of the
slain that sleep in the grave who now
remembers no more and they're cut off
from the hand they laid me in the lowest
pit in darkness and in the shadow of
death against me is thine anger made
strong and all thy Billows has thou
brought upon me that was remove my
friends apart from me they've made me an
Abomination unto themselves I've been
delivered up have not come forth my eyes
are grown weak from poverty I've Cried
unto thee Oh Lord the whole day long
I've stretched out my hands into the
name for the dead will that work wonders
shall Physicians raise them up they may
give thanks unto thee shall any in the
grave tell them thy mercy and of thy
truth and that destruction shall thy
wonders be known in that Darkness or thy
righteousness in that land that is
forgotten but as for me unto thee O Lord
have I cried in the morning shall my
prayer come before thee so you're kind
of lowered into the grave your kin are
standing afar off yeah
like it's such a deep coherence to the
imagery that that is used and it can
help you like you said you talked about
how the Psalms are in some ways a mini
version of scripture and I think they
are I think that the key to interpreting
scripture is often in the song because
it's a poem and because what the poet
does and you see that in Christian poets
too like if you read Saint Ephraim
that's what he does the analogies that
they create help you to understand what
the bible stories are about right and so
what you see in this in the psalmist is
that there are several things going on
one is that he goes down right so
imagine you know there's the Mountain of
God and he's going down the mountain of
God and going down the mountain of God
has
images related to it going underwater
right it talks about the ways the Billow
is going over me it talks about
fragmentation right it's like I am far
away from those that I love they can't
they every everything is broken and and
fragmented it talks about the enemies
it's like if I'm far away from God then
all the things from the outside assault
me like I'm assaulted by thing from the
outside then it relates it to sleep
relates it to Darkness but especially it
relates it to forgetting this idea that
I I have been forgotten by God I have
forgotten God and you see that like the
image of forgetting you see that in in
uh during the flood when when Noah is on
the on the waters at some point it says
God remembered Noah and when God
remembers knoweth as if in this darkness
and this deep there's this connection
you see it in the story of Jonah Jonah
goes down to the bottom then all these
same images come right the Deep the
darkness you know the death and sleep
and then and then he says I remembered
the Lord and he calls up right he calls
up to the mountain calls up to the to
the high place and these images are all
there like all these these songs that is
beautiful imagery to help us like
understand
like how can I say this to help us
understand how the story of the flood
relates to you like you said this is a
key for our own experience like how the
story of Moses through the desert the
the Egypt the Israelites being slaves in
Israel and being forgotten by God and
then God remembering them and what that
means it's like it's just giving us a
key to and showing us that scripture is
not
even in Scripture it tells us that the
other story that used those images are
about your experience right right yes no
I think that's that's wonderful and I
think
um right the way they kind of interweave
and overlap
um and then like Psalms is sort of like
the cherry on top it's sort of like okay
nice you've heard Jonah do it uh and and
you've heard Hezekiah do it and you know
you've heard Noah do it now it's your
turn right so it sort of puts us in the
sequence in a way so that we make this
this prayer as well
um
and so I I think
yes I love this I think you're right I
think there's such a commonality between
the metaphors that that come with death
and like being away from God and all the
things you mentioned and
um yes this land of forgetfulness right
so it's a kind of a place right it's
it's not just a psychic State I mean
there's definitely this idea that it's a
it's a place and you know as you said
you're far from family
um you have no strength you have no
Comfort
um it's it's just utterly painful
um
and
I think the song the six Psalms take us
right to that point they really just
drive us down and then
um
there's this unexpected turn in the six
songs right so when you get to the fifth
Psalm this see it seems to come out of
nowhere all of a sudden you have Psalm
102 bless the Lord on my soul and all it
is within me bless His holy name bless
the Lord O My Soul forget not all that
he hath done for thee he was gracious
unto all thine iniquities who healeth
all thine infirmities redeemeth thy life
from corruption which is this place
we're talking about who crowneth thee
with mercy and compassion
as for man his days are as the grass as
a flower of the field so shall he
Blossom forth for when the wind has
passed over it then it shall be gone and
no longer will it know the place thereof
but the mercy of the Lord is from
eternity even unto eternity upon them
that fear him so there's like this
moment and I think like you mentioned
Jonah right he too like remembers God
and His Temple and it's like he's able
to to kind of move to ascend in a way
even though he's still in the in the
belly of the fish
and like the the so you you sort of make
that Ascent by virtue of of remembrance
and so there's this like
um as as dark as it is the six Psalms
um I I just think this moment of like
remembering that you are not forgotten
is um is essential to the movement of
the songs and not only that but it helps
you understand it just helps you
understand so much about what we say
like why is it that we talk about memory
when we talk about the deceased you know
why do we say memory Eternal yeah we
have this sense in which we understand
that in that it is memory like it is God
remembering us that makes even our death
keeps us connected to God that that that
in this memory is how everything holds
together you know uh and so it it's a
key to understanding even how in the
church we treat the the dead and how we
the way in which liturgically we talk
about people that have passed wow I
never thought about that you're right
why we're always talking about memory um
but no it makes it makes perfect sense
and I mean and now now that you mention
it
um you know you have this burst of like
praise and the fifth Psalm but the sixth
Psalm you're kind of back down again so
it does not end on a high note it ends
on a low note but like to your point one
of the themes in that in the final Psalm
of the 6 is memory right uh oh Lord hear
my prayer give ear to my supplication
hearken unto me
um
enter not into judgment with thy servant
for a nice sight shall no man let living
be justified the enemy had persecuted my
soul it humbled my life down to the pit
he sat me in darkness as those that have
been long dead my spirit within he's
become despite it my heart is troubled
and then this like what you're talking
about memory I remembered days of old I
meditated on all thy works I pondered
the patient's life so memory kind of
keeps him like from succumbing to the
darkness in a way I should put my hands
unto thee so he moves he does something
my soul thirsteth after the like a
waterless land quickly Hear Me O Lord my
spirit had fainted away so it's sort of
from this dark place we have this sort
of
flash of like hope this burst of Hope
but then we kind of come back to this
place and realize really all that we
have in this place we're utterly kind of
helpless it's our capacity to cry to God
for mercy and that that comes from
I think the soul which is this part of
us that is like god-given and it's it's
we can ignore it we can suppress it but
we can't get rid of it and it's the part
that that helps us always to to cry out
to God and so even in this forsaken
place it's like you still have that
capacity to cry out to God for mercy and
and so
that's this whole image of the morning
like this one the morning that's coming
and it's Cycles it's as if it's not yet
the morning it's like I see the morning
you know I'll hear you in the morning
like I'll see you in the morning you
will you know that there'll be there'll
be this light that will come and
sometimes it's it feels like he's saying
that it's now but then he goes back into
the darkness but so there's this sense
like I know I I trust I hope I know that
you know that God will deliver me even
though at this moment I might not
be I might still be in this this
Darkness you know wait it's a it's both
very realistic but also trusting in this
trusting this absolutely knowing that
the light the light of God the
remembrance of God and God except God's
Mercy is the thing that will bring me
back into the light ultimately
now I think that's a great point I think
if the six songs ended on this sort of
high note and everything sort of you
know wraps up nicely
um then you know that wouldn't quite be
what what it's like I mean you call them
realistic and I think that's right I
think it is this sort of like I'm
despondent and and I and I'm in this
sort of waterless land but then I have
hope but then like oh wait but I have to
sustain that hope you know and and it's
a struggle right it's always a kind of
an argone like a a struggle
um so I just so that's the way the six
Psalms end
um and then the lights come on in the
church and then the the Deacon goes into
a litany and it's like oh hey I'm back
uh in the land of the living I'm praying
now for the patriarch and I'm praying
for other people and like I'm back
um but it's it's sort of like you are
invited to take this this journey and I
mean to to you know we have mountains
every day at same vlades which is a huge
blessing you really get to see how the
Psalms can tutor you and um so I think
this experience of going through death
uh every day
um by virtue of the six Psalms is
um one that like helps you realize how
important it is like you were saying
memory like to cultivate memory and
Remembrance and also to kind of
open the self in such a way that it's
its main
the central feature of its subjectivity
is is essentially this kind of relation
to God by which we beseech his Mercy
which is essentially the Jesus prayer
right like that's what the Jesus prayer
is doing but
um I think and then in the I mean in the
philocalia the idea of the memory of God
like it's so present it's so important
to understand that in some ways that is
the way that we are connected to God is
just it's just through attention and
memory like if we if we can live in that
in that memory then
I mean who like you would you would you
even sin like if you could just live in
the memory of God like how could you you
know always by forgetting it's like it's
always by forgetting my connection to
this higher
to the higher things that I fall into my
own idiosyncrasy and I think that I can
get away with this or I think that that
I'm isolated like this buffer itself and
that my thoughts don't matter that my
you know my actions don't matter but if
I remember God then how can I how can I
yeah how can I fall into these into
these these other types of patterns yeah
no exactly if only right if only exactly
I'm saying is it's as if I can do that
but it's like whatever moment that I
have where I'm able to live in that
memory and you know and and with the
Jesus prayer let's say feeds me and I
can it becomes a pattern for me then I
then I know that it's it makes
everything bright like it just happens
that you know this this image of the
morning and the light and the things
that that have the light of God that
shines on them shine on them yeah that's
what that's what happens
I mean so this possibility of sort of
keeping one's attention fixed on God at
all times is obviously you know
difficult but like I think that is the
Psalms right it's like you as you were
saying it's every situation in life how
to fix your attention to God when you're
when you're angry
um when you're just sort of filled with
joy in the temple worshiping God I mean
there are songs that go there
um there are Psalms that have to do with
conflict with other people right and
there are Psalms that have to do with
sitting by a brook and you see a deer
come and drink the water and you know
it's just every kind of experience there
is one in which it is possible to fix
one's attention on God so in a way like
the Psalms Bears witness to something
that we can do but but but don't uh
unfortunately yeah I know unfortunately
yeah but it but it's interesting because
at least like because we have the
Liturgy and because we can at least have
these moments where you know in some
ways how can I say this not that we're
forced to do it but that the the
external situation is kind of leading us
into it then we can have little glimpses
of that of that possibility
um no I yeah no I think that's you know
I think of the uh
I think the Liturgy is sort of obviously
the primary place where this happens for
us
um but you know we you can always you
always got this you can always you know
yeah just read read the psalter and kind
of go through the psalter
um like so there's this the feature of
the Psalms I think that's also
interesting is that the word Soul comes
up a lot and um so this is the you know
the Hebrew word nafesh which has a lot
of different meanings
um Netflix can actually refer to your
throat or your your neck so when when I
think it's Psalm 69 the waters have come
up to my nephesh probably means the
waters have come up to my neck you know
they're High
um
but it the word occurs in in a lot of in
you know a lot of different places in
the Psalms and I think in other places
you know it has
kind of there's something else going on
with this word in other words what I'm
saying um so when the soul is mentioned
it's the soul is always interested in
doing particular things
um and the Soul above all is always
interested in in connecting with God
right to you oh Lord I lift up my soul
As the deer pants for the flowing Stream
So my pants my soul for you oh God my
soul thirsts for God for the Living God
for God Alone my soul waits in silence
for him comes my salvation oh God you
are my God earnestly I Seek You My Soul
thirst for you which is not the same as
saying
um earnestly I see you know I thirst for
you right I wait in silence it's It's
You could argue grammatically that maybe
some that's basically what it amounts to
but I do think the language is important
here and um
one of my former teachers um James kugel
who's like you know really knows this
the the biblical poetry uh World very
well
um he had this funny term for the soul
in the songs he said the Psalms is a
kind of double agent that in in the
Psalms the soul is this sort of thing
that's in you that belongs to you
but God put it there and it belongs to
God so it's ultimately loyal to God
um and it's this part of you that's
loyal to God and is only kind of happy
let's say when it when when in contact
with God right so you can kind of be at
odds with yourself in the sense that
your soul which belongs to be in contact
with God uh isn't you know the things
you're doing it isn't you know what I
mean like the things that we do
um
and so you have this sort of paradox
where the the part of you that you
consider to be like most interior your
soul is actually only
at rest only at peace only fulfilled
when it goes beyond the boundary of the
self to uh to God so we definitely don't
want a buffer that's impenetrable right
uh the soul needs to move beyond that
but for to God and like the more porous
that is the easier it is for the soul to
come to to God and back again
um the more integrated uh the person
right so
you also have these other verses in the
Psalms where the psalmist addresses his
soul uh why are you downcast oh my soul
why are you in turmoil within me
um bless the Lord O My Soul all that is
within me return O my soul to your rest
for the Lord is dealt bountifully with
you and so you have this phenomenon of
like talking to your soul not just like
speaking but like talking to it you know
and I think this is different from when
we talk to ourselves you know where
we're just kind of verbalizing talking
to one's soul is to kind of face up to a
part of you like that is you but again
like not completely because it belongs
to God so you're facing up to a part of
you that is
um
that is loyal to God that will not rest
until it sees God
like just going back to subjectivity for
a minute like I think that is something
we experience is sort of this being at
odds with the self you know being
unhappy being fragmented being
um conflicted let's say and I don't know
I think sometimes we don't
we kind of misdiagnose it you know we're
like oh I'm just bored I'm just unhappy
I'm just Restless I'm just sort of
dissatisfied
um and it could be that the conflict
that's give making you unhappy has to do
with
um with this you know this soul that
rests in God and and and all of us who
you know sees on various distractions in
the world and prevent that from
happening
so I don't know I know do you think
there's a connection between this term
and the way that the the
say the Orthodox uh fathers talk about
the Noose for example like yes yeah I do
I do
um so yeah news isn't normally you know
a translation of nephesh but I but it's
like as I was thinking about it it
reminded me a lot about about news
language and like the part of us that's
that can perceive and apprehend and
relate to God
um and wants to and is continually
wanting to so like there's this core
feature of the self that you know we in
in Modern Life right in the confines of
the buffer itself tend not to even
acknowledge and I think this is where a
lot of our own kind of
unhappiness comes from yeah and there's
also a way in which you know this idea
of the soul for people or this idea of
the way you describe this this category
which is like in between in between in
the sense that it's the hook between
it's a place where God and you connect
you could say right the top of the
mountain like however you want to
describe it you know the holy of holies
there are many there are different
reflection of that of that place or that
reality in scripture from the individual
but then also you know when Moses goes
to the top of the mountain and then in
that in that place is where he receives
you know the glory of God and the same
thing in the Tabernacle you know in this
whole this place in Saint Gregor Nissa
really seems to join all of these
together and say basically they're just
the images of the same thing at
different levels of of reality but it's
also I think that for secular people
listening to this this is actually a
necessary aspect of how reality works
that is for things to exist they
necessarily have to have an aspect of
their existence which transcends it
which links it to higher participations
right this is this is absolutely
necessary for anything to to exist and
so you can't you can't find the purpose
of things in the thing it's always it's
always kind of in between in between the
thing itself and it's Telos you could
say and so the fact that this exists for
a cop or for anything is is just that's
just how it works and so the the notion
that we have that should not surprise
people like if you're not surprised
people that humans also have an aspect
of themselves which has to necessarily
transcend their multiplicity like this
this this connector for us to be be able
to exist with each other but then also
for us to be able to exist towards that
which is above us and in this case of
course we're talking about
the very source of reality itself right
the god of love so so I I think that
it's not a it's something which can be
posited almost technically for people
you know and that the the imagistic
language need not make you think that
this is some kind of magical
floating you know uh this is how people
sadly imagine the soul like right it's
like where is the soul as if it's it's a
physical physical thing where this is
not what we're talking about here
no it's it's it's so I I there's a kind
of
Paradox there right it's sort of you if
you if you enclose the object enclose
the thing in such a way that it has to
kind of be a kind of thing unto itself
in who's with with a kind of inherent
meaning right not only does he lose the
meaning you lose the object right so and
yeah and so like I think
um the Psalms kind of with this
continual opening of the self is is just
it's it's actually not a kind of
um escape from subjectivity but a kind
of fulfillment of it a kind of like
joining it with the world adjoining it
with God to joining it with reality that
makes the self not diminished but like
embedded and thereby kind of enhanced
and more real
um and if you understand that it that
way then what you talked about at the
beginning makes so much sense when you
said you know the mo the bet the mode of
being the mode of subjectivity is is
relationship that is the mo and so for
that to happen there has to be an aspect
of me which is calling out which is
almost like escaping my my closed self
in order to be able to connect with God
to connect with others this is this is
absolutely necessary
yes and you know I have to say I've had
some influence from you know
existentialist thinkers in the past you
know who kind of know that this is true
actually they know that that this is
part of what it means to be like they're
good phenomenologists they know that
this is how the mind works um but like
for them it's good enough that you just
posit it it doesn't really matter what's
on the other side it's like in the act
of positing that you can get the same
effect
um but um but can you yeah but can you I
mean is or do you know that you've
posited it in a way that kind of
undermines its ability to Anchor you and
I think the psalmist is always coming up
against God in a way that's like
God is not manipulable God is Not uh
yielding to him you know he's saying
listen listen help me out but God is is
doing it on God's terms right and so
there's a kind of like now we can talk
about objectivity in a certain sense
like there's a certain
you know aspect to um to God that is
like not you it's other than you and so
you cannot fake
um there's a kind of reality to that the
cat it can be like approximated maybe
but it can't ultimately be
be be reproduced it can you know it can
be counterfeited but it can't be you
know
it can't be reproduced in something yeah
let's to say in the ways that the people
watching this will totally understand
you can't completely just act as if God
exists yes
exactly exactly as if it's going to like
be you know it's gonna yeah it's gonna
act out so but that's why like I tell
people that ultimately the Psalms are
the good example this is that ultimately
worship is the key to this like we're
it's like it's because worship places
you in a mode where you're interacting
where you're acknowledging where you're
placing yourself in relationship to this
this to to God and then and then that is
the training right that's the training
ground which helps you exit you know not
just make it into a mental trick but
make it into something that you embody
that you participate in no I I think
that's absolutely important I think
that's that is the kind of real thing
ultimately is worship right and um and
uh you know I I am you know I do I just
love how in the church you know it's
it's that that kind of worship is so
full it's it's how you stand right it's
where you're looking it's what you're
seeing um iconographically it's what
you're hearing musically and you know
it's it's
um it's a kind of full bringing of the
self
um into God's presence and I'm learning
to stand in God's presence in a way that
is um it in a way it's sort of like
teaching you but in a way it's it's also
the thing itself and so there's a
completeness to our experience as human
beings in worship that isn't available
when we're you know being consumers or
we're you know
distracting ourselves in various ways
um and and it's not you know I say this
not as like not as like some great
liturgical athlete like oh I'm super I'm
like no I struggle and it's hard for me
because of the ways that I've you know
grown up in my own kind of mind but um
but I am grateful that everything is
there in place to kind of
to prepare us not not to create the
religion to prepare us to like
experience it
um fully so I do think liturgy and
participation in Services is is kind of
the main thing but like when you're not
you could be reading Psalms yeah yeah
but just even the Jesus prayer like you
said the Jesus prayers is a form of
memory it's a form of of just constant
participation and so it's it's always
accessible to us even if it's just for
30 seconds like just that moment when
you're in between things just that
moment when you're distracted when
you're nervous when you're anxious it's
like it's like the Jesus prayer is such
an amazing thing we can we can reach out
to to kind of put ourselves in that mode
of attention you know
so I think you know just just talking
about the soul and like there being some
part of us that is like constantly like
trying to go up you know you use the the
axial imagery you know and I think
that's true the soul is like the part
that's trying to go up all the time in
the flesh is the part that's trying to
like sink down all the time but
um so if like there is this part of us
um then a Jesus prayer is a kind of like
stepping out of like attention to one
thing onto attention
of the soul to God that's also real I
mean I think that I'm just being like
thinking about criticism oh the Jesus
prayer that's just like a nervous tick
or like oh that's just something you
know you're saying or that's just like
something you're saying like
therapeutically just to make yourself
feel better but no it's not so you are
actually it's like there's an electrical
current there you know with the soul to
God and you're kind of plugging in as
long as you can you know and then you
know maybe you can't plug in for
for a long time but you can plug in for
a few minutes and then that that changes
you right like there's an energy there
yeah but that but it's all once you
understand the role of memory and
attention and the way in which we exist
in relationship to others but also I
mean just even in terms of our
relationship like memory and attention
is how you stay connected to your
friends to your family to all the people
that that are around you and so this
idea that it's that it would be
arbitrary that you would have these you
would try to have memory and attention
in your in your life in your daily life
towards God like just like you said just
connect even for just 30 seconds one
minute you know like waiting waiting
outside for someone or whatever to just
kind of go into the Jesus prayer that's
ridiculous it's like it's actually it
will create a a basic
strata of what you are like it'll create
a basic spread of what's most important
to you
yeah I um I was just reminded of
something I heard a while ago about how
kind of the currency and in the digital
economy is attention right like that's
what right and and it's it's sort of
like when
when you kind of realize that um and
then you kind of pair that with you know
I think the truth that you're you're
articulating here about attention being
kind of what we have it sort of raises
the stakes in our daily lives right like
we think oh it's an innocent thing that
I'm doing this and I'm confusing my
attention and here and there but uh and
it's easier than ever to diffuse one's
into attention but oh yeah
our world is made to scatter us like
everything about it is like is made to
rip us apart so yeah it's difficult but
you know in some ways it's like it's
it's weird because it's difficult but at
least
at this moment we have the capacity to
see it because the fact that that we
online the cycles of attention are so
accelerated and the scattering of
attention is so immediate we can realize
to what extent attention is the mode it
is the mode of connection like that's
what it is so you're like wait a minute
it's so I think that it in some ways it
is opening up the possibility of people
to understand that and to re-enter into
at least we enter into that space where
it's like Yeah well yeah where I put my
attention is probably one of the most
important things that I can decide what
I'm doing
okay so I think we have to add that to
like an unsharing of subjectivity not
just cognitive or effective but like
it's kind of like yeah yeah so we hear
it in the in the Liturgy all the time
it's like a 10. that's it attend you
know stand up attend you know that's and
that's that's that's a good start you
know
yeah I mean and they're kind of timed in
a certain way like oh yeah okay right
they kind of like bring you back um so
uh no that's good I didn't make that
connection but um
no that's I don't know how do we yeah
attention yeah I think that's um
the psalmist is is he he might be like
he might be impatient or he might be
angry or he might you know he might be
any number of things at any given moment
or even pretty dark almost despairing
but like always attentive right yeah
that's the kind of Baseline of it is
like God I'm looking to you I'm
attending to you are you gonna help me
and are you gonna you know save me or or
thank you so much or I'm going to praise
you and I'll page you as long as I live
you know but whatever whatever he is on
that in his life at the moment
that that's certainly what's there yeah
Michael this has been a great
conversation thanks for having it and
I'm looking forward I'm going to be at
Saint Vladimir's in April and so I hope
that I can meet you that would be
wonderful day oh and that's exciting
okay I'll look forward to welcoming you
on campus and thanks for having me
Michelle I did I enjoyed it a lot I
appreciate the time all right so we'll
see how people react to this you know we
always look forward to your comments and
and who knows maybe we'll have another
discussion very good excellent thanks
okay